doseki's most interesting man in the
world campaign invited consumers to be
more like its fabled subject a deep
voice narrator admiringly in tones this
guy's accomplishments which include the
fact that his shirts don't wrinkle he
bowls overhand he tips 100 and he's won
a Lifetime Achievement Award twice each
ad eventually cuts to a bearded man
who's surrounded by women as he hoists a
bottle of Dos Equis stay thirsty my
friends Jonathan Goldsmith portrayed the
most interesting man in the world
capping a career as a character actor
that began in the early 60s during the
80s he guest starred on seemingly every
major TV drama of the decade including
Knight Rider The A-Team and Dallas
following his work as the most
interesting man in the world Goldsmith
popped up at the end of 2018's Mamma Mia
here we go again as a man looking for
some late in life romance then in 2017
he published his Memoir entitled stay
interesting